from pepsi references to supernatural
reunions to billy butcher's secret love
for his dog terror there is no end to
the incredibly detailed easter eggs
hidden all throughout amazon prime's hit
show but only true fans notice these
things from season 3 of the boys
in season 3 the boys find themselves
going up against an all-new suit soldier
boy technically soldier boy isn't new to
the superhero game he's the first
powered up living weapon vault created
and he's been a part of the company for
a long time according to the
vault-approved version of his biography
his service in world war ii included
storming the beaches on d-day and he
continued working with vaught into the
vietnam war like homelanders soldier boy
has incredible strength and impenetrable
skin he also doesn't seem to age and has
more than a handful of personality
quirks like compulsive marijuana smoking
or casually homicidal tendencies to cite
two examples it makes him a profoundly
unreliable hero soldier boy reportedly
died in the 1980s at the beginning of
the season butcher is investigating how
the seemingly unbeatable soldier boy was
finally defeated maeve helps butcher's
investigation as her own form of
rebellion against vaught and the intel
she gives him in the first episode of
the season also includes a hint at
soulja boy's real personality maeve
gives butcher a file on soldier boy
which prominently features the name
raymond l s patriarca it's not clear
whether soulja boy is this universe's
version of the real world rhode island
lobster or soulja boy worked for him as
a member of the la cosa nostra gang but
the file definitely shows us that
soldier boy was in jail when bot
discovered him despite his unsavory past
bot still decided to give him powers it
turns out bot's penchant for creating
ill-behaved superhumans goes back to the
very beginning of its history
to outsiders billy joel's music probably
seems like a bizarre pairing with the
extra raunchy hyper-violent content to
the boys but the piano man is intimately
connected with the show in the very
first episode of the boys huey and his
girlfriend robin are having an intense
debate about the merits of billy joel's
music when a train kills her that
incident might have changed huey's
relationship with his favorite recording
artist but it also marks the beginning
of some great needle drops in the amazon
prime series season 2 features multiple
billy joel songs and the artist was
excited enough to tweet his support for
the show the connection continues into
season 3 but this time the music is even
more thematically appropriate uptown
girl plays in the first episode of the
season over a montage of huey's
near-perfect life with annie and working
for the federal bureau of superhuman
affairs the song marks a new high point
for huey but it also comes back over the
episode's credits just after huey
discovers that his boss is the head
popping soup who first begins
terrorizing people back in season 2.
huey might love some billy joel but the
music isn't always a good omen for his
immediate future
most of the time billy butcher comes
across as cold calculating and heartless
but every so often there's a small hint
indicating that butcher has a softer
side in the boy's comics butcher's dog
terror is a regular member of the team
butcher's affection for the bulldog
shows he does have some capacity to care
for something other than himself he
simply chooses to do so in an extremely
selective terror specific capacity
butcher's fur baby has a small role in
season 2 but for the most part tv
audiences have missed out on that part
of butcher's life that's probably
because as showrunner eric kripke knows
how difficult it is to work with animals
ultimately having terror join the boys
on their misadventures regularly turned
out to be too much of a hassle while
terra might not be helping in the effort
to bring down homelander in season 3 he
isn't absent from the show entirely this
season sees butcher spruce up his
kitchen counter at home with a cookie
jar that looks identical to terror
beneath that tough exterior butcher is a
softy when it comes to dogs
tv shows cost millions of dollars to put
together and raising that kind of money
can be a real challenge most shows and
even movies tend to include some product
placement to pay the bills even though
amazon certainly isn't hurting for money
the boys has done the same seeing real
world products in a fictional universe
can sometimes feel jarring but the boys
have been able to include products in a
way that fits into the story in a more
or less natural way in season three huey
and annie's relationship is going better
than ever but it's not completely smooth
sailing shortly after homelander reveals
that he killed supersonic huey has his
own bombshell to drop on annie so he
decides to soften the blow with some
candy and white claw whether or not the
brand name boozy seltzer seems out of
place is up for debates but the candy
almond joy charleston chew and bitter
honey actually has real significance to
the in-show history of the boys during
season two when huey and annie start
building their relationship he finds out
that those are her favorite kinds of
candy at the time hui calls out annie's
taste those are the like three worst
candy bars in the history of candy
clearly he's filed away the information
for later use
there have always been clear parallels
between vaught in the world of the boys
and disney both companies have histories
that go back to the early 20th century
and both function as massive
entertainment companies that also pursue
numerous side projects in the form of
corporate subsidiaries in season three
the bought disney associations become
even more heavy-handed and not just
because we see much more of payback the
series original in-universe answer to
the avengers than usual bought land is
exactly what you'd expect from an
alternate reality disneyland kimiko and
frenchie have to make their way through
a section of the park called brave
maeve's inclusive kingdom and their walk
is packed with hilarious details clearly
vaude is capitalizing on maeve's
identity in a way only a soulless mega
conglomerate can they also scramble to
make the public forget about the literal
nazi who occupied a prominent and
influential position in the seven until
very recently on top of ridiculous
caricatures of bought heroes and an
unbelievable amount of rainbow flags the
inclusive kingdom also has some searing
jabs at corporate appropriation of
social justice issues kimiko and
frenchie walk past food vendors like blm
blts woke wok and a mexican food stand
with a menu that includes systemically
oppressed tacos vod isn't going to lose
out on marketing opportunities no matter
how shameless they are
truly there is no god here
the relationship between homelander and
vaught executive madeline stillwell was
a major focus of the first season of the
boys which premiered in 2019 homelanders
jealousy of madeleine's son became a
huge point of conflict for the two of
them right up until homelander burned a
hole in madeleine's head in the season
finale in the years since that dramatic
moment the ultimate fate of madeleine's
son teddy has been a mystery but season
three quietly reveals that teddy is
alive and well huey's investigation of
his boss victoria newman leads him to
the red river institute the institute
operates as a home for young soups whose
parents either abandoned them or died in
a powers-related accident when huey
arrives at red river he pretends that he
and annie are interested in adopting the
child so we can get a closer look at
what's happening behind the scenes well
samir is south asian
that is very hot right now
and one of the institute's classrooms
huey has a brief interaction with a
young teleporting boy who turns out to
be little teddy the season doesn't
reveal how teddy became a soup but the
reveal has some believing that teddy is
actually homelander's son i'll have to
wait until season 4 for more details
soldier boy's history with voc goes all
the way back to the company's earliest
days he's been out of the picture since
the 80s but he has intimate knowledge of
the first several decades of ott's
roster of soups and also made an
outsized impact on soup culture as
soldier boy reveals he's the founder of
the annual hirogasm event when he
discovers that hirogasm is still running
almost four decades after his apparent
death he clearly takes a little bit of
pride in its longevity soulja boy brags
about his history with hirogasm to huey
and butcher and in doing so he also
reveals a shocking detail about his
history with stormfront he tells the
others that he created the first
hirogasm alongside her but calls her by
a telling name i founded it in 52.
me and this other soup liberty man was
she a firecracker
season two of the boys revealed that
stormfront was once called liberty
before vaught forced her to undergo a
rebranding neither huey nor butcher
tells soldier boy what became of his old
friend and as far as we know he doesn't
discover liberty's fate for himself
before the end of season 3 considering
homelanders intimate history with
stormfronts maybe it's better for
everyone if this truth remains buried
before working on the boys showrunner
eric kripke was the mastermind behind
another wildly successful tv series
supernatural ran for well over 300
episodes on the cw launched the career
of jensen ackles and inspired a prequel
series called the winchesters season 3
of the boys sees echols join the show as
soldier boy but he isn't the only
supernatural alumnus who's part of the
amazon prime series in addition to
accols this season of the boys also
includes appearances from other
supernatural actors gatling griffith
plays gunpowder in flashback sequences
this season and he previously appeared
as jesse turner in the supernatural
episode i believe the children are our
future the season also reintroduces jim
beaver as presidential candidate robert
singer beaver played the character bobby
singer on supernatural and both
characters grew up in south dakota
dakota bob as he's called by some in the
boys could become even more important in
season 4.
the boys is loaded with social and
political satire but the show's main
characters are so caught up in their
battle against vaught and the supes that
they hardly ever have time to stop and
directly address issues that also exist
in our world a train and blue hawk
provide an exception to this rule in
season 3 by offering their perspectives
on police brutality and systemic racism
however dipping into the discourse of
current events doesn't pan out so hot
for either of them despite the
prominence of soups in this universe
there's plenty of overlap between the
political history of the boys and our
own some background details in season 3
can help fans better understand how one
character in particular relates to some
of the most important issues in recent
history mm's apartment becomes a regular
hangout for the characters this season
and in addition to meticulously cleaning
the place mm has also decorated it with
political memorabilia hanging above his
tv is a move on over or will move on
over using that was adopted by the black
panthers in the 1960s in shots of mm's
entryway fans can spot a framed picture
of president barack obama hung above a
vote ue newton poster mm himself is much
too young to have been a member of the
black panthers but it's not a stretch to
imagine that his father had time to
participate in the movement in between
his legal battles with vaude and soldier
boy when it comes to attention to detail
the boyz goes above and beyond most
other shows it's not just that the boys
is filled with references to other
series or small details about the
history of its world the team behind
amazon series also takes care to
accurately recreate the feel of
ridiculous commercials and cable news
segments they also never miss an
opportunity to sneak in a joke which
means that anytime a news segment is on
screen the ticker at the bottom of the
screen is running with some hilarious
detail in season 3 the trend of ticker
jokes begins in the very first episode
the news is covering a group of
stormfront sympathizers who call
themselves storm chasers the ticker at
the bottom explains that some storm
chasers have gathered to await the
return of jfk jr and something some
real-life conspiracy theorists believed
would happen back in 2021 they were
disappointed when the assassinated
president and his deceased son never
showed
the news ticker jokes and the boys are
almost always poking fun at some real
life figure or group in the season three
finale a news ticker takes a jab at
texas senator ted cruz it says that cruz
was caught trying to leave a hotel
without paying for the pornography that
he ordered in his room it's those kinds
of small details that make the boys
spectacular to watch again and again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the boys are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one